Speaker 1: There is a growing talking point
that there is an assassination plot against
Donald Trump now. Almost certainly there are
people who would love to assassinate every
former president and every current president. Joe
Biden gets assassination threats. Trump got them.
Barack Obama got more than any previous president.
George W Bush got them. Okay. So in some general
sense, the point of the Secret Service, among
other things, is to track and pay attention to and
investigate assassination threats against a former
or sitting president. But there is a growing
talking point among the American right wing, the
MAGA people, that the FBI raid on Trump's home
is part of a growing assassination plot.
Now, before we even look at the clips and
the first clip is going to be from from
Steve Bannon. You have to at some point
apply some basic level of critical thinking to
this stuff. And you should be saying if there was
an assassination plot against Donald Trump,
why would a legally executed search warrant
on his home be part of the assassination plot?
Why? Why would you need that if you're I mean,
for the people that believe that the CIA killed
John F Kennedy. Why would they have needed to
first serve a search warrant on his Hyannis Port
home or the Kennedy compound or whatever? It just
doesn't make sense. You don't need a legal FBI
raid as part of an assassination plot, but this
doesn't matter to them. This doesn't stop them.
Let's look at this first clip. And by the way,
if it's Steve Bannon, so it's not merely
an assassination plot, it's a deep state
assassination plot. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: And I agree. I do not think it's
beyond this administrative state and their deep
state apparatus to actually try to work on the
assassination of President Trump. I think. I think
everything's on the table. I think security ought
to be at the highest it's ever been. And honestly,
I think he ought to and I think he should have
flown down in Mar a Lago this morning, walked out
there at noon today and said, hey, I'm running
for president, United States. Suck on that.
Speaker 3: Well, that was my next question
as his former top adviser. What
should Trump be doing right now?
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 2: I think what we what
he should do is action, action, action. I don't
think there should be any more of the tweets,
no more of the true social stuff. That's all nice.
Speaker 1: Listen, there's not going to be
any tweets. He's been banned
from Twitter for a long time.
Speaker 2: They put out a video last
night. No more videos. We're beyond that.
You know, they're trying to not just put you in
bankruptcy. They're trying to liquidate Infowars,
which is obviously one of the major news sources
out there for the MAGA movement. They're trying
to liquidate MAGA Infowars. They're putting
Peter Navarro in chains like a common self.
Speaker 1: All right. So anyway, the deep
state is working to assassinate Donald
Trump and there's been planted materials at
Mar a Lago, no evidence of any of that stuff.
Then on Newsmax, and we looked at this earlier
in the week. Here's Bernie Kerik. And I should
actually be precise about Bernie Kerik because
I alluded to this and then I was not completely
sure about it. Bernie Kerik is former police
commissioner, but also a convict. He pleaded
guilty in Bronx Supreme Court to ethics violations
and acknowledged that when he was interior
minister of Iraq, he accepted a quarter million
dollar interest free loan. And loan is in quotes.
It's not really clear what the deal is with that.
Then he was indicted by a federal grand jury the
following year in White Plains, New York, on
charges of tax fraud making false statements
in 2009. He then pleaded guilty to eight felony
tax and false statement charges. This guy if this
guy if anybody knows about criminality,
it's Bernie Kerik. And he is on to say,
I think they may be trying to assassinate
Trump with all of this. And again,
the question is, Bernie, you used to be in
law enforcement. Why do you need to execute
a search warrant in order to assassinate someone?
Speaker 2: And I just put out a tweet about this.
If you remember, back in 2016 where I went right
before he got elected, I was in Washington,
D.C. I was at a couple different social events and
I heard people talking. They said the Democrats
want this guy so bad that they wouldn't put
assassination behind it. And I'm going to tell
you something, please. They've tried impeachment.
They've tried another impeachment. They've tried
one investigation after another. This is about
one thing. This is about stopping him from running
in 2024. And I'm going to tell you something.
I'm not into conspiracies, right? I'm not into
anti-government rhetoric. This is the first
time in my lifetime that I would say I am
deathly afraid for Donald Trump. I would not put
assassination behind these people. I you know,
a very good point, Bernie. He gets Secret Service
for the rest of his life. Based on what we
have known recently, what we hear about
Deep State, he may find it in his best
interest to get his own security with the secret.
Speaker 1: You'll understand that the deep state
may be so deep. It may be in the Secret Service.
The Secret Service may have it out for Trump,
and thus Trump should have private security to
protect him from the Secret Service, which is
there to protect him from everybody else as well.
Speaker 2: Bernie, about 20 seconds left. Final
thought. I listen, I couldn't agree
more. You know, what just happened
is no different than what
happens in Venezuela, Colombia,
Cuba and countries like that.
Speaker 1: Unfortunately, it really doesn't happen
in a lot of those countries. And a lot of those
countries you would never see a search warrant
conducted on a current or former official. You
wouldn't see it because they actually don't have
the the administration's control law enforcement
and they control courts. And these are the
horrible things in some of the places that they
talk about. So you actually would not see that. No
evidence for any of this. No evidence for any of
this. But they're talking about planted evidence.
They're talking about assassinations. They will
not stop and they are throwing everything they can
at the wall to see what sticks. We'll have more
coverage of all of this on our Facebook. Make sure
that you have found our Facebook page,
facebook.com, slash The David Pakman
Show. And remember that if you've been missing
all this week, we've been doing livestreams,
covering the latest revelations on all of
this. If you've been missing the livestreams,
you can see the top clips from the
livestreams on the second YouTube
channel. That channel is called Pacman
Live and you can find it at YouTube.com
slash Pacman Live. Believe it or not, that's
where you can find it. Don't miss the live
stream coverage. We will take a quick break and
be right back. Much more news to discuss today